a leak of a draft opinion shows that the  supreme court is going to formally  overturn roe versus wade and planned  parenthood versus casey it is written by  justice solido joined by justices thomas  gorsuch kavanaugh and barrett it appears  to be legitimate and there are no  denials from the supreme court now this  draft may change it's from february 10th  there will be some negotiating from the  other justices who will have some notes  notably justice roberts does not appear  to join in the decision and while rowan  casey have been effectively dead for  months this opinion would formally and  explicitly overturn those cases largely  on the basis that the rights granted by  roe and casey are not quote deeply  rooted in the pastor's prudence of  american british law so for a scotus  opinion this is stark and in your face  there are absolutely no punches pulled  but it remains to be seen what the final  version will look like